[موسيقى]
تامر بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر بتوقيت
الرياض انا صهيب شراير وهذه اخبار الساعه
الالماني يترك اوكرانيا في مواجهه صعبه
بمعركه الربيع فهل هو خروج عن السر ام خوف
على روسيا
حرب اوكرانيا تستنزف مخزون البنتاجون
العسكريه الحرب تستهلك صواريخ ستينجر بما
يوازي ما صدرته امريكا خلال 20 عام
بعد سيل العقوبات الدوليه المتزامنه على
ايران جدل حول الاليات القانونيه لادراج
الحرس الثوري على قوائم الارهاب
300 مليون دولار في اليوم الواحد
تهريب الدولار يفجر ازمه جديده في العراق
ويفتح ملفات الفساد والسوداني يكشف ارقاما
صادما عن بيع العمله
في بريطانيا واتهامات للحكومه بالتقصير في
حمايتهم
[موسيقى]
اوقات اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه سواء كانت
انفراجه ام التفافه فان موافقه المانيا
الدبابات الى كيف لم تلبي طموحات اوكرانيا
التعنت الالمانيه لارسال الدبابات يعتبرته
دول اوروبيه خروج
انقسام المعسكر الاوروبي في ملف الحرب
وتاكد ان برلين خائفه من روسيا لكن امام
التعنت الالمانيه تخرج بارقه امل
للاوكرانيين بعد اعلان بولندا عزمها ارسال
دبابات الالمانيه لاوكرانيا عاجلا ام اجلا
وتاسيس تحالف من دول مستعده لارسال
الدبابات كما جاء التطوينات اوروبيه اليوم
بمواصله دعم اوكرانيا مهما طال الامر
واتفاق دول الاتحاد على ارسال حزمه سابعه
من المساعدات العسكريه الاوكرانيا بقيمه
بخمسمائه مليون يورو
الدبابات الثقيله راس الحربه في اي هجوم
او دفاع توفر مستوى عاليا جدا من الحمايه
ضد اسلحه النيران المباشره
تساعد في التحرك بسرعه على الطرق
والتضاريس الوعره تعمل على الاتجاهات
الحاسمه وخرق المناطق المحصنه والنفاذ عمق
العدو
تعد القوه الضاربه الاهم في القوه
العسكريه لاي جيش
تنفذ عمليات والتطبيق وشاطر الدفاعات
العدو وتدميرها
تمتلك قوه اختراق اكبر
وتوفر القوه الناريه والقدره على المناوره
حاجه اوكرانيا الملحه لهذه الدبابات ياتي
اولا لان اليوفنتر الالمانيه يمكن ان تحدث
فرقا حقيقيا في ساحه القتال وهذا لما
تتمتع به من مميزات كاجهزه استشعار جيده
وقدره قتاليه متطوره فهي بحسب الخبراء
افضل بكثير من النماذج الصوفيه ولهذا يوصل
الاوكرانيون الضغط للحصول على عده مئات
منها ليس من اجل الدفاع عن مواقعهم
الحاليه فقط بل لنقل القتال الى العدو
روسيا في الاشهر المقبله بحسب مسؤولين
اوكرانيين سيما وان الاشهر المقبله حاسمه
بالفعل مع اقتراب موعد معركه الربيع
الدمويه
تابع مع مراسلي العربيه من موسكو برلين
مرحبا بكما راغده العلي ابدا معكي بولندا
مستعده اذا لتسليم اوكرانيا دبابات
الالمانيه حتى وان لم توافق برلين هل هناك
اي رد فعل او اي شيء عن الحكومه الالمانيه
حياله موضوع الدبابات الالمانيه لاوكرانيا
المانيا
من بولندا ولا اي اي دوله اخرى بارسال هذه
الدبابات اثنين الى اوكرانيا وتقول بانها
عندما تحصل على هذا الطلب ستدرسه ولكن
ايضا لم تحدث فتره زمنيه المتحدث باسم
الحكومه قال بان هذا الامر قد يستغرق ايام
وقد يستغرق اشهر او اسابيع بمعنى انه ايضا
رفض ان يقول متى يمكن ان يعطى هذا القرار
عندما ياتي هذا الطلب الى برلين ولكنه
ايضا كان هناك تحذير للدول او لفولندا
تحديدا لان هي التي تقول بانها قد ترسل
هذه الدبابات من دون موافقه المانيا عندما
سئل المتحدث عن هذا عن هذا الامر قال انه
نتوقع من الدول الحنيفه بان تلتزم بالعقود
بالموقع بيننا بمعنى العقود التي وقعت
عندما تم شراء هذه الدبابات تنص على ضرو
اخذ موافقه الحكومه قبل ان يتم ارسالها
الى دوله ثالثه
لذلك لان ننتظر لنعرف اذا كانت ستقرر
برلين ومتى ستقرر وما هو الجواب الذي
ستعطيه او اذا كانت بالفعل هذه الخلافات
متجهه نحو التصعيد اكثر
عبد الجواد كيف تتعاطى موسكو مع هذا
الانقسام الغربي خاصه مع هذا التردد
الالماني في تسليم كيف دبابات ليوبارد
مساء الخير صهيب لك رغد نعم بالفعل يعني
لا يمكن اخفاء حقيقه خلق موسكو من تسليم
الدبابات الالمانيه
للحكومه الاوكرانيه او للقوات المسلحه
الاخرانيه لكن موسكو اليوم اصبحت يعني
ووقفت عن الحديث عن تسليم هذه الدبابات
واصبحت تتحدث بشكل اكبر عن ان تسليم هذا
السلاح الغربي من العيار الثقيل لكيف قد
يطيل عمر الازمه لفتاه طويله لكنها تتحدث
بامكانيه وقدرات موسكو على تدمير هذه
الدبابات في حال دخلت الى الاوكرانيه صهيب
طبعا ما يقلق موسكو الان هو المرحله التي
ستاتي بعد تزويد النظام كيف الدبابات لانه
موسكو اصبح حتى انه عاجل ستصل هذه
الدبابات
لكن لما يقلق موسكو هي الصواريخ بعيده
المدى التي قطط المناطق اخرى موسكو
عذرا على المقاطعه عن المرحله المقبله من
هذه الحرب نتحدث في الفقره التاليه عبد
الجواد وراغده ارجو ان تبقى معي ساعود
اليكما بعد قليل مشاهدينا ايضا روسيا ساعه
لتعليق القتال في فصل الشتاء لتعزيز
قواتها واعاده تجميع صفوفها في خطوه اثبتت
انها كانت تمثل الهدوء الذي يسلك العاصفه
عاصفه من المقرر ان تهب على اوكرانيا في
الربيع المقبل حيث تستعد موسكو لشن هجوم
جديد قد يوسع نطاق الصراع ومن جانبها اعلى
من شبكه سينان ان اوكرانيا تسابق الزمن
وتنشد خلفائها الغربيين لمدها بالمزيد من
الاسلحه والمعدات العسكريه استعدادا لما
تسمى معركه الربيع التي يرجح البعض انها
ستكون دمويه واستعدادا لهذه المعركه معركه
الربيع افادت مصادر عسكريه الاوكرانيه بان
روسيا قامت بتدريب ودمج نحو اربع مئه الف
جنديه الروسيه تم التجنيده في الخريف
الماضي في وحدات جاهزه للمعركه لم تقتصر
الاستعدادات الروسيه عند هذه النقطه سواء
ساعات لتجهيز عشرات الالاف من المقاتلين
من مجموعه فاجنر العسكريه المعركه الوشيكه
دفعت برئيس الروسي فلاديمر بوتين لصب
تركيزه على تدشين طائرات مسيره خصيصا
للقتال المرتقب وفقا لمعهد دراسات الحرب
الامريكي تقرير معهد دراسه الحرب الامريكي
كشف ان هدفا المعركه هذه المره بنسبه
لبوتين هو السيطره على العاصمه كيف وسائر
الاراضي الاوكرانيه فالرئيس الروسي لا
يمانع في خوض معركه طويله الامد مهما كانت
كلفتها
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
واعود الى مراسلين في برلين وموسكو راغده
وعبد الجواد راغده اعود اليك هنا هذا
التردد الالماني او عدم الحسم في دعم
اوكرانيا بالمزيد من الدبابات كان هناك
حديث كذلك عن انقسام في داخل الحكومه
الالمانيه واذا ما ازداد الضغط على
الاوكرانيين مع معركه الربيع هذه المرتقبه
هل يمكن ان يغير المستشار الالماني او
تغير المانيا الموقفها من مساله دعم
الاوكرانيه
المانيا تشدد على انها من اكثر الدول التي
تقدم دعم عسكري وانساني ويعني غيره الى
اوكرانيا اليوم المتحدث كان يقول المتحدث
باسم الحكومه كان يقول بانه المانيا ثاني
دوله بعد الولايات المتحده قدمت دعم عسكري
حتى الان لاوكرانيا مذكرا بانه حتى ولو ان
المانيا الان لم تقرر بعد مساله ارسال
الدبابات من غيرها ولكنها بالفعل ارسلت
عدد كبير من الاسلحه منها منظومه دفاعيه
ومنها مدرعات لحمل الجنود همم وغيرها يعني
من الاسلحه في الاشهر القليله الماضيه
لذلك هنا هناك حرص من المانيا على ان لا
تظهر وكانها الان هي التي تعيق جهود او هي
التي تعيق نعم ولكن
المحللون عندك في المانيا هذا الموقف الان
همم هل هو خوف من روسيا ام على روسيا
هو خشيه من رد فعل روسيا وزير الدفاع
الالماني قال قبل يومين بانه يجب ان ندرس
جديا ما هو ما هي نتائج ارسال هذه
الدبابات المتحدث باسم الحكومه كان يقول
يجب ان لا تظهر دول الناتو اي دوله من
الناتو وكانها متورطه في هذا الحرب تخشى
المانيا من ان تنظر روسيا الى هذه الاليه
العسكريه التي قد تحدث تغير على الارض على
انها يعني ربما التدخل مباشر من المانيا
وهذا قد يورط دول الحلف بالطبع هذه مخاوف
الحزب الاشتراكي تحديدا داخل الحكومه
الحزبين الاخرين لا يتشاجران هذا الراي
وهم بالفعل كما ذكرت صهيب يزيدان من
الضغوط جدا على المستشعر الى الشغل لكي
يسمح بارسال هذه الدبابات
الحرب الامريكي يتحدث على ان المرحله
المقبله معركه الربيع تتضمن خطب بوتن
لاستلاء على العاصمه الاوكرانيات كيف ما
المعطيات المتوفره حول معركه الربيع
لما همم تحضر له موسكو في في الربيع
صهيب يعني يد متر مدفيدف قبل النحوي همم
اربع ساعات من الان تحدث عن ان العالم
مقبل على حرب عالميه ثالثه ايضا خرج
الرئيس الاركان العامه منذ نحو ساعتين
وقال ان موسكو اصبحت تواجه الغرب بشكل كلي
خلال هذه الفتره وهذا لم يحدث خلال تاريخ
روسيا المعاصر لذلك طبعا معظم وكافه
الاوصاد في روسيا اصبحت تدرك بان هذه
الحرب هي طويله وموسكو كما نلاحظ من
تصعيدها العسكري ان كان في الاراضي
الاوكرانيه حيث دخل الدبابات ارماتا وهي
احدث الدبابات الروسيه المعلن عنها
الطائرات المروحيات والمقاتلات وقد اطلقت
على ما يبدو صهيب يعني خططتها العسكريه
على مرحلتين الاولى طبعا تكمن في الفرقات
والقواصات الحامله للصواريخ النوويه
والصاروخيه وغيرها بالاضافه الى تجميع
قواها في الاتحاد العسكري مع الجانب
البيلاروسي قد يشهد الجميع طبعا اج احلى
الاراضي الاوكرانيه ودخول كيف من الشمال
من المناطق البيلاروسيه وقطع الطريقه
اوكرانيا يعني من الشمال الى الجنوب وقطع
خط الامدادات هو ضرب سكك الحديد فسيمنع
وصول هذه الدبابات صهيب او السلاح الغربي
الثقيل الى كيف المرحله كما يرى الروسيه
مقبله على حرب طويله هي حرب قاسيه بداها
الروس الان بهذا التصعيد ومرحله الربيع
الذي يعني الذي تتحدث عنها التقارير
الغربيه هي بدات لدى موسكو الان حسب روايه
موسكو اسرائيل
شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
التردد الغربي هذا مشاهدينا في فتح الدعم
العسكري على مصراعيه لاوكرانيا
استهلكت صواريخ ستينجر بما يوازي مصدرته
امريكا خلال 20 عاما فبات مخزون السلاح
الحالي غير كافر في وقت الحرب
الادنى من المستويات
اين ذهب مخزون اكبر سلاح مملوك للدوله في
العالم حسب دراسه عسكريه
في وقت تنظم فيه مخزوناتها العسكريه السبب
الابرز الذي وضع امريكا في مازقه
واستنزافه اوكرانيا بعض مخزوناتها من
السلاح حيث تستهلكت اوكرانيا سبع سنوات من
انتاج امريكا لصواريخ بالاضافه الى
استهلاكها لما يوازي ما صدرته امريكا خلال
20 عاما من صواريخ ستينجر
الولايات المتحده لارسال اكثر من 27 مليار
دولار من المعدات العسكريه الى اوكرانيا
في موقف لا تحسد عليه
مركز دراسات الاستراتيجيه والدوليه
[موسيقى]
تجاه اوكرانيا جعل مخزونها من الترسانه
العسكريه بوضع حرج وخطر استراتيجي
في وقت الحرب
ستواجه مشكله في الذخيره تؤثر على قدرتها
على حمايه نفسها او خلفائها عسكريه وهو ما
قد يغير قواعد المواجهه حسب المركز
الامريكي في وقت تجد شركه الدفاع نفسها
غير قادره على استرجاع المخزونات
المستنفذه بسرعه او موكبه المفاجاه
العسكريه
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه الخان الاحمر في
القدس تهجير على خطى حي الشيخ جراح
واهدافه اسرائيليه اخطر من الترحيل
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد
حزمه عقوبه جديده ضد قاده ايراني
تبعتها بريطانيا باعلان التجميد اصول قاده
ايرانيين واصول ميليشيا البسيج التي تعتبر
بمثابه ذراع للحرس الثوري ومن ثم الخزانه
الامريكيه التي فرضت عقوبات استهدفت 10
افراد والمؤسسه التعاونيه التابعه للحرس
الثوري وشامله القائمه الامريكيه الجديده
ايضا عقوبات على نائب وزير المخابرات
الايراني
ادراج الحرس الثوري على قوائم الارهاب لكن
هذه الخطوه ترى جدلا من حيث الاليه
القانونيه لتنفيذها حيث يتطلب وتصنيف
الحرس الثوري منظمه ارهابيه قرارا قضائيا
رسميا هذا ما اكد عليه مسؤول السياسه
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل
مؤكدا ان التكتل لا يمكنه ادراج الحرس
الثوري الايراني على قائمه الكيانات
الارهابيه الا بعد صدور قرار من محكمه في
الاتحاد يفيد بذلك وبهذا وهذا يتطلب بحسب
البريل ادانه قانونيه ملموسع
ايديج شمس
لا يمكن ادراج الحرس الثوري الايرانيه على
قوائم الارهاب دون قرار قضائي قرار
المحكمه اولا فلا يمكن تصنيف اي شخص بسبب
كره له لذلك يجب اصدار القرار عندما تقر
دوله اوروبيه حكما رسميا بناءا على اساس
قويه حينها يمكن العمل على المستوى
الاوروبي
بريطانيا وجدت مخرجا قانونيا في ملف ادراج
الحرس الطوري الايرانيه على قائمه
الجماعات الارهابيه القانون المنتظر وفقا
لهيئه الاذاعه البريطانيه من المقرر ان
يحضر انشطه الحرس الثوري ومعاقبه المنتمين
اليه داخل المملكه المتحده وبموجب قانون
الارهاب الصادر عام 2000 ستلاحق الحكومه
البريطانيه كل من يحضر اجتماعات الحرس
الثوري ويمنع رفع شعار
المجموعه الايرانيه في الاماكن العامه
[موسيقى]
معنا من لندن دكتور احمد عجاج استاذ
العلاقات الدوليه دكتور احمد اهلا بك معنا
ما هي الاليه القانونيه حتى يتمكن الاتحاد
الاوروبي من ادراج الحرس الثوري الايراني
على قائمه الارهاب الاوروبيه
نبدا بالاوروبيه لانه هناك خلاف يعني بين
الاتحاد الاوروبي وبريطانيا وانت تطرقت
الى ذلك في بدايه الحديث بالنسبه للاتحاد
الاوروبي طبعا من الصعب جدا يعني تنفيذ
هذه القرار بهذه الطريقه السريعه لان
البرلمان الاوروبي يعني صوت على اعلان
باعتبار منظمه الحرس الثوري منظمه ارهابيه
لكن هذا يعود الى المجلس الاوروبي الذي
يضم 27 دوله ويجب جميعهم ان يوافقوا
بالاجماع دون استثناء على ذلك واذا
موافقوا جميعا بالاستثناء في يمكن عند اذن
نتحدث
جوزيف تحدث على انه يجب ان تكون هناك
ادانا بواقع عمل موسى يعني ان يكون هناك
اثبات بانه الحرس طيب هناك رعايه اوروبيون
همم محتجزون لدى النظام الايراني هناك
اعتقال وهناك منهم حتى من يواجه حكما
بالاعدام يعني الاء همم لا يشكل هذا
ادانتا لممارسه النظام الايراني
نعم يجب ان نفرق هنا عندما تحدث بالقانون
بين عمل تقوم به الدوله وعمل يقوم به
الافراد منظمات ليس لها علاقه بالدوله
الحرس الثوري هو جزء من كيان الدوله الذي
لحقت له احتقار القوه وبالتالي فان تصنيفه
كمنظمه ارهابيه هو غير معتاد عليه في
التعامل الدولي ولذلك هو قال يجب ان يصدر
حكما قضائيا يثبت ان هذا الجهاز في الدوله
بادله بانه قد قام بالفعل بعمل ارهابيه
وبعدها يمكن البدء بحظره وليس فقط يعني
حكم القضائيا بل حسب القانون الاوروبي او
اي هيئه موازيه للقضاء او من خلال بلد
ثالث صدر فيه حكم ولديه ادله يمكن بعد اذن
الباحث في ذلك المشكله بانه غير متعارف
عليه في الدول ان تصنف جهاز من اجهزه
الدوله عمل منظم ارهابيه ولذلك لابد من
صدور تشريع جديد
يضعه ضمن هذه التصنيف كما يحدث
بريطانيا الان بمشروع قانون الامن الوطني
حيث هناك بنود عامه يمكن ان تصنف تحته
منظمه الحرس الثوري منظم ارهابيه بل ان
حزب العمال طالبا بتعديل هذه النصوص لكي
لا يكون فيها نوع من اللفظ وجعلها صريحه
لتصنيفه يعني في عظمه ارهابيه لكن حتى في
بريطانيا بموجب قانون الارهاب لعام 2000
لا يمكن تصنيفه منظمه ارهابيه السبب كما
قلت عليك ان هناك سياسه منذ عام 1870 في
بريطانيا وحتى في اوروبا لا يتصنف
الكيانات التابعه للدوله بانها ارهابيه
وهذا ما حدث عندما اغتال جواسيسروس
المواطن البريطاني
ومواط الروسي في الثالث بروك لم تتهم
روسيه بانها دوله ارهابيه وان المخابرات
جهاز هذه بل استعمل اشخاص شكرا جزيلا لكم
الدكتور احمد عجاج الدوليه
[موسيقى]
الى العراق وعلى موقع ازمه في دولار غير
مسبوقه ارقام صادمه كشف عن رئيس الوزراء
العراقيه محمد شيع السوداني بشان بيع
الدولار السوداني قال لان البلاد كانت
تبيعه 300 مليون دولار في اليوم الواحد
فيما عجز الاقتصاديون عن تفسير ما الذي
يستورده العراق حتى يبيع يوميا بهذا الرقم
واشدد السوداني على ان حكومته جاده في
تطبيق المعايير الصحيحه التي تضمن
المحافظه على الماء العام
هذه النافذه نافذه بيع العمله فيها هدر
وفيها اموال تخرج بغطاء تجاره غير مشروعه
تهريب غسيل اموال شتتهم
والتحليلات
واغلبها صحيح يعني لا ليس في اطار التهمه
كنا نبيع 300 مليون دولار في اليوم الواحد
وكل الاقتصاديين والمختصين يقفون عاجزين
على تفسير انه ما الذي يستورده العراق
يوميا حتى يبيع 300 مليون دولار
هذا ولا تزول الاسواق العراقيه تشهد
ارتفاع الملحوظه في سعر صرف الدولار امام
الدينار الامر الذي ادى الى اطاحه بمحافظه
البنك المركزي وتعيين اخر من قبل رئيس
الحكومه لمواجهه ازمه الدولار بسلسله
جديده من الاجراءات
السلام عليكم
هذه الجمله هي الاكثر تداولا هنا في
الاسواق العراقيه
حيث لا يكاد يمر الا وارتفع معه سعر الصرف
وتزايدت المخاوف من تكرار سيناريو انهيار
العمله اللبنانيه في العراق على الاخوه في
الاداره العراقيه التعاون مع الفدرالي
الامريكي لحل الازمه لان المتضرر صراحه
التهاجره
الفقير الضرر المستهلك الضرر
كل
الامور في بغداد الان واقفه بسبب ارتفاع
الدولار الغير طبيعي
دولار تسبب لهم بمشاكل ماليه
كلها اللحوم عندنا الدجاج كله تركي ايراني
كله صعب الدولار
[موسيقى]
كنت بصالح البنك المركزي وبصالح الاقتصاد
لترصين اكثر القرار حضيه بغطاء كامل من
تلاف اداره الدوله ومن الاطار التنسيقي
واا تقديري اي الخطوات التي اتخذت الحكومه
خطوات جريئه وقويه وفاعله
وستؤثر بشكل سريع همم يعني على مستوى
السوق في اعاده التوازن الى سعر العمله
القديمه
الدينار وخسارته نحو عشره بالمئه من قيمه
الدينار شكل تحديا حقيقيا لحكومه السودان
لانه يمص الطبقات الفقيره بشكل مباشر
الامر الذي ينذر بتحركات شعبيه على مستوى
الشارع اذا ما استمرت قيمه الدولار في
الصعود امام الدينار بالتسامح مع اقاله
محافظ البنك المركزي شهده الاسواق الماليه
انخفاض النسبيا في اسعار صرف الدولار امام
الدينار لكن يبقى سؤال هنا هل سيستمر هذا
الانخفاض ام سيكون بشكل مؤقت سامر كويتي
العربيه بغداد
وامام هذه الازمه نذكره بما كشفت هيئه
النزاهه الاتحاديه في تقريرها عام 2022 عن
مقدار الضرر بالخزينه العامه البالغ ما
يقرب من 4 تريليونات دينار عراقي جراء
فساد نافذه بيعه
ازمه الدولار بالعراق
غير قانونيه
تطبيق بفواتير مصارف عراقيه كشف الكثير من
الفواتير المزوره
من بيع الدولار كعوب تقرير هيئه النزاهه
الاتحاديه عام 2022 اكبر عمليه فصاد تتم
من خلال مزاد العمره
الخزينه
العراقيه
تابعه لايران
معنى من بغداد مراسل العربيه مسجد حميد
مجد اهلا بك معنا ما طبيعه هذه الاجراءات
التي تمتخاذها حتى حصلت ازمه الدولار في
العراق المستمره الان
نعم الاجراءات التي تمت من قبل واشنطن
طالبت من البنك المركزي العراقي بان يكون
عمليه بيع الدولار من خلال النافذه
الكترونيه وان يتم تدقيق الفواتير التي
يتم من خلالها دخول المزاد من قبل المسار
في الاهليه وعلى ان تدقق هذه الفواتير من
قبل هيئه الجمارك عند عمليه استيراد
المواد كنا رئيس الوزراء السوداني قد اشعر
بان هناك في عمليه الفواتير التي تصل الى
البنك المركزي الى العراقي لذلك حدثت
عمليه زياده في عمليه الصرف للدولار امام
الدينار العراقي ارتفعت بمقدار اكثر من 20
نقطه لكنها تراجعت قبل قليل من الان بناء
على القرارات التي اتخذت من قبل الحكومه
العراقيه بقاله المحافظه وتعيين محافظه
جديد لكن عمليه ليس من الممكن التنبؤ
بعمليه ان تعود ان يعود الدولار الى عمليه
الصرف الاولى اي
148,000 دينار عراقي امام كل
رجل السفيره
نعم هل ااا بدات هذه الاجراءات تؤتي في
مرهم من ناحيه مكافحه الفساد هل تراجعت
عمليات ال- ال- الفساد المرتبطه بهذه
التحويلات بالدولار
نعم عمليا هناك عمليه تراجع لان الكثير من
المصارف العراقيه الاهليه لم تعد تتقدم
الى المزاد لاخذ الدولار لان الكثير من
هذه الفواتير مزوره وهي لا تحمل فواتير
اصليه لكي تتقدم بعمليه شراء الدولار من
البنك المركزي العراقي بناء على هذه هذه
الفواتير الازمه الحقيقيه في في في في في
عمليه تقديم فواتير مزوره من هذه المصارف
لشراء الدولار ومن ثم تهريب الى الخارج
وتحديدا الى ايران وسوريا واشنطن قامت
بمراقبه اربع مصاريف منها الشرق الاوسط
وطلبت من البنك المركزي العراقي بان لا
يقوم بعمليه همم دفع الدولار باتجاه هذه
المصارف مما ادى الى عمليه زياده في
الدولار لكن الحكومه العراقيه من خلال
البنوك الاهليه هي تقوم ببيع الدولار بشكل
رسمي ب 148 الف دينار عراقي لكل مئه دولار
لكن عمليه المضاربه ما بين بين بعض البنوك
الاهليه وكذلك السوق السوداء هي التي دفعت
بعمليه رفع الدولار لذلك دفعت وزاره
داخليه بعمليه تفتيش من خلال ما يعرف
باللجنه الاقتصاديه وكذلك اجراءات حكوميه
للحد من عمليه الصعود لكن الان هناك عمليه
تراجع لكن ربما غدا في ساعات الاولى لفتح
السوق العراقيه ربما نشهد هل سيبقى
الدولار همم يتقدم باتجاه الدينار العراقي
ام ستتم رجوعه لكن الى مستوى محدد شكرا
جزيلا لك ماجد حميد من بغداد
[موسيقى]
في تكرار جديد لسياسه التهجير التي
تمارسها اسرائيل بحق الفلسطينيين يعود
المشهد الى الخان الاحمر وهي قريه تقع شرق
القدس يهددها قرار اسرائيلي بالهدم وتهجير
سكانها هو مشروع اوسع من الخان الاحمر في
الاسرائيليون او اسرائيل تخطط لما هو اخطر
من ذلك لاخلاء القريه وكل التجمعات
البدويه المجاوره وطرد الفلسطينيين منها
لاقامه ما تسميه مشروع القدس الكبرى مشروع
يهدف للابتلاء على الاراضي الفلسطينيه
الممتده من شرق القدس وحتى البحر الميت
وتفريغ المنطقه من اي تواجد فلسطيني
من الجانب الفلسطيني من نكبه جديده
يعود الصخبوا الى هذه القريه البدويه
الهادئه يراقب ابو العز المشهد وقد عاد
خوف التهجير يعتريه دون ان يفهم لماذا فهو
وعائلته يعيشون على هذه الثلاث الصخريه
منذ نحو 70 عاما ولم يسبق ان اعتدوا او
اضروا بحياه احد لو توجه الكاميرا
فيها اكثر من 70 سنه شايف يعني من قبل من
سنه الخمسين واحنا موجودين ترى هجرونا اول
مره من العراق
واليوم ضاقت عليهم صار بدهم والبدو من هذا
مقلوبه من ابو العز عشرات ومن الناشطين
الفلسطينيين يرفعون الرايات ويهتفون ضد
الهدم والاخلاء وعلى التله المقابله نواب
وكنيست من حزب النقود برفقه قوه من الشرطه
والامن الاسرائيليه يتظاهرون لتعجيل اخلاء
القريه وتهجير اهلها هي بوابه القدس
الشرقيه هي وكل هذه التجمعات المحيطه من
هنا حتى البحر الميت تن همم مخطط المشروع
المشروع ايوان يعني لف هذه المنطقه بعد
اخلاء هذه المناطق من التجمعات الفلسطينيه
بحزام الاستيطاني حول مدينه القصب الثالثه
تنفيذ الحلم الصهيوني القديم الجديد
المتجدد باقامه القدس الكبرى
في قريه الخان الاحمر يعيش 180 بدويه روح
له في خمسينيات القرن الماضي من منطقه
النقب وفي القريه مدرسه تخدم باقي
التجمعات في المنطقه وقد صدر قبل اربع
سنوات قرار من المحاكم الاسرائيليه بهدم
القريه ونقل سكانها لكن الضغوط الدوليه
على الحكومات الاسرائيليه المتعاقبه حاله
دون تنفيذ القرار
خطر الهدم والاخلاق يعود ليخيم على هذه
القريه البدويه اكثر من اي وقت مضى لاسيه
ان هناك وزراء في حكومه نتنياهو باتو
يربطون وجودهم ضمن الائتلاف الحكومي
بانهاء وجود هؤلاء السكاني على ارضهن من
قريه الخان الاحمر عبد الحفيظ جوان
العربيه الاراضي الفلسطينيه
معي من رام الله عزام الاحمد عضو لجنه
التنفيذيه لمنظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه سعيد
باستقبالك معنا سيد
عزام الاحمد معنا هذا المساء بدايه هل
الخان الاحمر هي اييي الشيخ جراح الجديده
يعني
تكاد تكون هكذا الشيخ جراح في وسط مدينه
القدس
والخان الاحمر تتبع محافظه القدس
والعيون
الاسرائيليه والاطماع الاسرائيليه تتجه
نحوها منذ اكثر من 40 او 50 عاما وهي تسعى
وتحاول الى ضمها الى القدس
كمتداد
لمستوطنه عليه ادوميم لتربيتها بمستوطنه
مع المستوطنات التي بعد الخان الاحمر
باتجاه البحر الميت ونهر الاردن
بهدفين اولا
لتصبح القدس
تشكل 25%
من مساحه الضفه الغربيه
بكاملها وتقسم الضفه الغربيه قسمين
اضافه الى
عابر السامره الذي يقسم القسم الاخر الى
قسمين تصبح ثلاثه اقسام اي
الحيلوله دون قيام دوله فلسطينيه وفق قرار
حل الدولتين الذي اعتمد في الامم المتحده
واختصر الكثير من الاشياء عن الاهداف هذه
الخطوه ولماذا تعود هذه همم هذه الرغبه
الاسرائيليه في طرد سكان الخان الاحمر من
منزلهم لكن السؤال هنا كان هناك تحرك دولي
من همم جهات دوليه منها الاتحاد الاوروبي
دعوا اسرائيل الى عدم اخلاء الخان الاحمر
ويخرج سكانه منه بالقوه هل تتوقعون
استجابه من الحكومه الاسرائيليه او رضوخا
من نتنياه لهذا الضغط الدولي
يعني الان
نتنياهو عاده
قضيه الخان الاحمر هو الذي فجراها عندما
كان رئيس الحكومه وبعد صمود
ابناء الشعب الفلسطيني
مع اشقائهم في الخان الاحمر
صمودهم اضافه الى الالتفاف الدعم الدولي
لهم ومنهم دول الاتحاد الاوروبي حتى اذكر
كان القناصل الاوروبيين ياتوا ويشاركوا في
الاحتجاجات ويعتصموا من اجل دعم صمود
اهالي الخان الاحمر المدرسه البسيطه
الموجوده
والتي تطورت يعني بناها الاتحاد الاوروبي
قد تستغرب بنوها من
عجال القوس قوس السيارات
وتوسعت المدرسه والا تضم 120 طالب وطالبه
مدرسه مختلطه و 22
مدرسه بها
ومن اجل دعم صموده وتدخلت محكمه الجنايات
الدوليه في ذلك الوقت واخذت قرار بمنع
التهجير ومنع هدم اشكرك
سكان الخان الاحمر اشكركم شكرا جزيلا على
حضوركم معنا احمد انتم عضو لجنه التنفيذيه
لمنظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه من رام الله
[موسيقى]
الى بريطانيا حيث اختفى العشرات من
الاطفال طالبين اللجوء غير المصحبين
بدويهم في بريطانيا
وصفها مبلغ عنها باختطافهم من قبل عصابات
الاجراميه وافقا ما جاء في تقرير
ان من
136 طفل مفقودا في الاشهر الثمانيه عشر
الماضيه لا يزال 79 منهم في عداد
المفقودين وتطالب المجموعه العماليه في
مجلس بلديه مدينه برايتون باجراء تحقيق
عاجل في القضيه
اختفاءه عشرات الاطفال من طالب اللجوء
كانوا يقيمون في هذا الفندق الذي تديره
وزاره الداخليه يثير صدمه كبيره في
الاوساط السياسيه والحقوقيه في بريطانيا
مع كشف تحقيق انما يقارب من 80 طفلا لا
يزالنا في عداد المفقودين
واقعه تقشعر لها الابدان بالرمي من
التحذيرات المتكرره لوزاره الداخليه بان
الاطفال اللاجئين غير مسحوبين بدويهم
مستهدفون من قبل الشبكات الاجراميه وربما
يتم الاتجار ببعضهم بعيدا عن الفندق الذي
ياويههم
وكانه مشهد من فيلم لا تتوقع ان يحدث في
اي مكان في مكان معين هنا في المملكه
المتحده
وتحديد مكانهم ومعرفه سبب اختفائهم
حالات اختفاء اطفال اللاجئين التي وصفها
احد الموظفين مع شركه لحمايه الاطفال
متعاقده مع وزاره الداخليه سجلت ايضا في
فنادق اخرى ماذا دفع القياده العماليه في
مجلس برايتون الى المطالبه باجراء تحقيق
عاجل في الاطفال المفقودين
اذا ما كان الاطفال في امان وحصلنا ضمنات
بان كل شيء على ما يرام ومن ثم بدانا نسمع
باشاعات ان الامور ليست كذلك
وكشفت بيانات رسميه قبل اربعه اشهر انها
222 من طالب اللجوء فقدوا من فنادقات تشرف
عليها وزاره الداخليه وحينها اعترف
الوزراء بانه ليست لديهم فكره عن مكان
وجودهم
المعارضه انتقلت وزاره الداخليه لاخفاقها
في حمايه سلامه الاطفال او قمع العصابات
الاجراميه التي تعرضهم للخطر وطلبت بوضعه
ترتيبات جديده لحمايتهم على وجه السرعه
والكشف عن عدد المفقودين والاجراءات التي
تمتخادها للعثور عليهم من مدينه بريطانيا
العربيه
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه في افغانستان
فتيات يتحدينا قمع طالبان عبر مدارس سري
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد في اليوم الدولي للتعليم
الذي يصادف الثلاثاء يلتفت العالم بقلق
لوضع الفتيات في افغانستان بعد منعهن من
التعليم لكن الياس لم يتمكن منهن فلجات
الفتيات الافغانيات للدفاع عن حقهن في
التعليم عبر المدارس السريه
افغانستان بلد تحكمه حركه طالبان بقوه
السلاح وحكم يقول لا مكان للنساء
والفتيات عن الحياه العامه
وحرمتهن من حقوقهن الاساسيه احدها الحق في
التعليم الا ان الافغانيات دافعنا عنه
بسلاح المدارس السريه في كل صباح باحد
افقر احياء العاصمه كابول تجتمع فتيات في
منزل للدراسه هو جزء من شبكه من ثمان
مدارس في خمس مدن تقدم خدماتها سرا
وبالمجان تدعمها منظمه
في المناطق الشديده التاثر بحضر مدارس
البنات
على الحكم في افغانستان عام 2021 الا ان
هناك ما يقرب من 250 امراه تاثرنا بحذر
طالبان للتعليم في التسعينات هنا انفسهن
يبحثنا عنهم مجددا في المدارس السريه رغم
الخطر الذي يواجه المعلمات طالبات الا
انهن يتمسكن بالتعليم المتحديات احتمال
التعرض للاعتقال والقتل
ويتحايلنا على اعين عناصر الحركه باخفاء
ادوات التعليم وسلك طرق طويله ومختلفه
نتركوك كتبنا في المنزل وفي الفصل اذا كان
لدينا واجب منزلي نكتبه على قطعه من الورق
بقلمنا ونضعه في جيبنا
العائق الوحيد امام المدارس السريه ليس
سهلا اذ ان سريتها ثانيه عدم حصول
الطالبات على شهادات رسميه وتدق ناقوسم
خوف ظهور جيل من الفتيات عشنا حاضرا وسط
الحرب والقمع
وبانتظارهن مستقبل رائع روان حمزه العربي
الالمانيه يترك اوكرانيا في مواجهه صعبه
بمعركه الربيع فهل هو خروج عن السرب ام
خوف على روسيا
اوكرانيا تستنزف مخزون البنتاجون العسكريه
الحرب تستهلك صواريخ ستينجر بما يوازيما
صددته امريكا خلال 20 عاما
بعد سيل العقوبه الدوليه المتزامنه على
ايران جدل حول الاليه القانونيه الادراج
الحرس الثوري على قوائم الارهاب
تهريب الدولار راي فجر ازمه جديده في
العراق ويفتح ملفات الفساد والسوداني يكشف
ارقام صادمه عن بيع العمله
العربيه تتبع خيوط فضيحه اختفاء عشرات
الاطفال اللاجئين في بريطانيا واتهامات
للحكومه بالتقصير في حمايتهم شكرا لكم على
كرم المشاهدات
[موسيقى]